when I met God there was a happiness
that I never felt before ever in my life
and that happiness is I I can only find
in God God makes me happy not these same
sex lifestyle not the LGBT
lifestyle and I don't want to go back
there because what I have now is so much
more fulfilling so much
more h
it's more it's so much more I actually
don't know how else to describe it
[Music]
um warning this episode may contain
content that is not suitable for
children viewer discretion is
advised how's it going everyone welcome
back to another LED live we've got a
great show in store for you today we've
got with us Wayne Blakeley and Daisy
snan all the way from South Africa and
what these two have in common is that
they both have once lived in the lgbtq
plus lifestyle Community both have been
set free by the blood of Christ and have
decided to leave that lifestyle behind
and really Embrace and accept the um
Christian um lifestyle as as portrayed
in the Bible and now in full-time
Ministry so Wayne real quick
can you briefly describe your basically
coming out of the lgbtq plus lifestyle
and coming uh into the Christian
lifestyle and relationship with Jesus
yeah I've been raised in a Christian
home it's just that as I developed samex
attraction I didn't know what to do with
it and it wasn't real clear in the
church you know we we didn't talk in
ways more clearly about it then like we
do today so I went into the LGBT
community thinking that's where I
belonged I mean people were very
receptive of me and you know it had its
own set of of uh ideas that you know am
matched my feelings and so I I went
there and lived there for 40 years and
you know there wasn't I certainly didn't
have a relationship with God or a walk
with God in that process um and I came
to the end of that road in the sense
that um after 40 years and we had been
hit with the AIDS pandemic all of the
sudden all of my friends are dead I mean
literally every single last one of them
are are dead and I'm sitting
contemplating one day yeah I wonder what
my destiny is because here I am I should
be dead and I'm not why why has God
preserved my life and so I began to
investigate what it was that God
actually wanted from me and I I
determined that what he was asking from
me was Intimacy in other words M rather
than just an acknowledgement of his
presence more about how to get to know
him courting him spending time with him
um learning to surrender myself and
abide in his ways instead of what my
feelings were directing me to do and
when I came back into the church which
was what ultimately happened in 2009 I
found that the whole 40 years I'd been
gone the church had still remained
silent and so um God opened up to the
idea that you know a Ministry was needed
not just to LGBT people but also what
was needed was education and Clarity
from God's word being presented to con
the congregation at large and even
leadership today so you know it's been
interesting to hear the stories of how
God has reached so many individual
people and you know I happened to know a
little bit about Daisy's story and was
blessed to hear that and how God met her
so you know I'm sure we'll be blessed
today yeah so Daisy you are with coming
up Ministries correct that's right I've
been with him for four years so what
what is coming up Ministries what do you
guys do uh as Christians who once live
that lifestyle well my particular part
of why I became a part of the team is I
I wanted to use the skills that God has
given me like artistically wise video
editing and audio editing and so Michael
said yeah we can we can use someone like
you and I also told him Michael Kushi
that's who I'm speaking about and I I
told him listen is there any way that I
can also play a part in witnessing to
others because
I really appreciate coming out
Ministries coming into my life and it
answered a lot of questions for me and I
wanted to talk to others that has that
same kind of questions and maybe even
help them and be a part in uh coming out
Ministries I just that's why that's why
I wanted to be a part of it you know
yeah I want to make a difference so you
are definitely making a difference now
you know also representing coming up
Ministries by doing things like being on
the show with us today uh L live so
bring back to the beginning like how
when did you start noticing that you had
same seex attractions and what do you
think was the cause of that oh
goodness well I I only accepted my
feelings when I was about in grade 12
then I was convinced myself like okay
this is this is who I am this is how
it's going to be but before that I was
confused and I didn't understand why I
was feeling like this because I had same
six attaction I didn't like guys and uh
it felt weird to me and I've realized
now that it started when I was a child
see my parents got divorced when I
was in grade one already and my mother I
stayed with my mother most of the time
and I could tell that she had this fear
of being alone so she had a lot of
boyfriends uh coming in and coming out
and and their relationship was very
physical and I I didn't realiz I mean I
was like eight years old at first I
didn't understand it
but until the one time my mother was
open and I could see what they doing
and and it always seemed like they
didn't care that I was there but
as it as it continues with their
different
relationships I got to learn that guys
only want one thing they don't know how
to love a women in fact I learned what
love was at that stage that love was
lost that is the image that I learned
and also with the image that I built of
men I didn't didn't want anything to do
with them because they are selfish they
only want one thing
so I think after dealing with all of
that all of the boyfriends coming in and
out I kind of trained myself in a way
that I don't want ever want to be in a
relationship with the man I want the
affection of a mother right but that
affection I didn't really get because
she was always so busy and uh cuz she's
single mom working and trying to find a
life partner you know I was just in the
background so I had this need for
motherly love but I also realized in
school that the girls were very
sympathetic you know they're very caring
but the guys at school they they're mean
you know they can be mean and they are
bullies and all of that so I started to
want more of that sympathy and that
empathy that girls have so I grew more
and more closer to girls and
uh the more I grew closer to girls the
more I started to get these attractions
as I hit puberty I was attract attracted
to wom because they gave me something
that I never knew I lacked and that is
affection and tenderness and that caring
and so I didn't have it as child but
these girls could give it to me I want
more of it and
so I started to explore more of it so in
grade 12 I had my first female
relationship my first girlfriend and it
went out it went on about a year but
again remember as a child I didn't know
what love was I Associated love with
lust so I relationship wasn't based on
love it was just physical and I thought
that is what fulfilled me that is what I
needed but it never filled my deep
desire to wanting to be
loved by a mother that is something
subconsciously I always wanted and so I
expressed it in ways that I thought I
knew was the right way to express but
boy was that all yeah so
after grade 12 uh by that
stage I properly looked like a boy
because I grew up with only guy friends
for some strange reason but the friends
that I had was always guys and so I
could always relate to the guys in a way
that they're rough and they want the
affection of girls and so I hanged
around a lot of guys during my primary
school and high school there was now
this was now before grade 12 before I
made the decision that this is who I am
this is how I'm going to live so before
that I learned how to be a
boy and strangely enough I didn't know
it then but back then I believed that I
was a
boy even when in primary school I
realized that
listen I'm not supposed to be a woman I
have affection for women
and so that means I'm a
boy it just it just made sense to me in
my head at
that I almost want to say vulnerable age
that I was in so I started to dress like
a boy I believe that was a boy
subconsciously but I didn't say it and
people confused me a lot uh some would
even ask my mother is that a boy or girl
you know and and that kind of affected
me as well and uh people would even have
the courage to ask me hey are you a boy
or a girl wow and so I had yeah and I I
had to deal with all of these issues of
I don't know what my identity is Daisy
was that was that insulting to you or or
in that process did you think oh yeah I
I did you feel good that they thought
that you were a boy or did you know
enough about at that point how you
should
feel yeah I I was heavily affected
because people saw me
as a boy unless I've told them listen
I'm a girl so I was offended because I
wasn't born a boy but that's what people
saw so I was offended and I I was just
confused just brought on more confusion
confusion of my identity and I I wanted
to know who I was people tell me I'm
this and I feel like that and I'm
attracted to wom but I'm not supposed to
you know I had all these question marks
Did did you have people like put you
down or shame you for any of this
um yeah I was bullied I I was bullied in
high school because I had
this horrific skin problem right it was
so bad that I used the lid of my cream
pot because I had a special cream that I
had to use for my Eczema and
uh it could be in it was so hot at times
but I had to cover myself so much that
it'll confuse people even more of what I
was I see I had this really short hair
um and and imagine really short hair and
covered up clothes and you know there's
this dress coat in high school girls was
wear skirts and the guys wear shorts or
long pants so I went to the principal or
my mother went asking for permission so
that I can wear the long pads because
his eczema was so severe I you when I
get home after a hot day I would scratch
my skin with this cream liit pot making
it even worse m just to get rid of that
itch it was
so
unbearable and
um what happened was after I scratched
myself with this lid I would pour a
crazy hot
bath like the type of hot where you put
your hand in it burns and you take it
out it's you you know you have this
blood red hand I don't know if you've
ever experienced a hot part like that is
yeah so I would basically give myself
second degree burn in that b yeah I just
scratched myself and raw and now I burn
myself and it's quite interesting when I
get out of that b and I burn myself and
I'm so sore uh I realized that I I
didn't fall in the category of cutting
myself to get rid of pain but I burned
myself and when I get out of that
b i I don't know how to explain it I
just had this sense I didn't think of
anything else just gave me such a relief
um that I I'm not thinking about what
happened in that day or the guys
bullying
me because they didn't
understand they didn't understand point
and in that moment when I get out of
that b and think of anything like that
anything that happened because I was in
pain and it felt good
wow it felt so good such a relief but
then when I go to bed every morning I
have to peel my clothes off my skin um
because I was bleeding so much and
wow so it could be even 100° at school
in high school and I would be wearing
long pants and a jacket I was
miserable and so my high school was not
a happy memory had all so I had all
these questions about myself people
telling me who I am what I am bullying
me making fun of me I just so what in
that period of time what was the
atmosphere so you're living just with a
mom at that point
right and and you don't have a whole lot
of nurturing from your mother it doesn't
sound like at that time no I had no
nurture in fact they they thought that I
was happy my mother and my so they just
let me be and do whatever whatever I
wanted it when in reality you're in a
bit of a private
hell was I was miserable living in hell
and they didn't realize because I didn't
tell them even and like I said single
mom working don't really pay that much
attention to me so she didn't ask any
questions uh she just let me be and my
dad as well he just let me be so I I
would go visit him now and then um but I
stayed majority of the time with my
mom and I I also have to mention that
not too long ago during Co my mother
came and apologized to me wow in tears
that she wasn't a good mother she said
that the Holy Spirit convicted her of
the fact that she was living
a life of sin and she just apologized to
me that she wasn't there she wasn't the
mother that she knew now that she
wasn't so yeah I just felt like I needed
to mention that as well but at the time
my mother wasn't prison at all so so so
you're going in to school right um
you're having problems with your skin it
makes you have to cover yourself up you
have to wear pants you have short hair
so everybody thinks you're are a boy
um how does the story continue on from
here like you have a girlfriend Etc you
broke up what happens after that well
after that in grade 12 after my year
relationship the reason we broke broke
it off is because I had to go study in a
different city which is quite far from
her and we knew that long distance
wasn't wasn't going to
work so I went to study and my first day
arriving there I was petrified because I
knew how high school was and I knew how
primary school was and I'm just
wondering oh man what is University
going to be like what are they going to
throw in my face oh but my first day I
arrived really short ha and and then I
had funny
enough I had these short pants but it
was just over my
knees now the reason why I found my
myself in short pants is because that
December
holiday um after I finished high
school I someone in I think it was my
cousins that inspired me to start
wearing short pants because I'm killing
myself here is excruciating hot and I'm
wearing t-shirts but still the long
pants so the ocean water was actually so
beneficial for my skin it was so bad but
for some reason that ocean water just
cleared up my skin and I still had the
scars but now with the short pants I got
a little bit of a tan so I had I had a
bit more confidence in wearing shorts at
University but it was these boys shorts
I always bought clo clothing on the
men's uh the men's section so these boy
shorts and these weird t-shirt it had
this like a baby face on it and that
baby face had like piercings in the nose
on the ear and I just looked weird was
really weird look Looking Back Now at it
and I'm just thinking oh
Daisy but again I I I didn't
realize what I was who I was I just
dressed and talks according to what I've
learned and saw and experienced in my
life before for from when I was a child
so everything I wore was my mind
thinking this is what I was supposed to
wear this is what I'm supposed to look
like which was as we know a bunch of
bogus but
anyway so my first day there and I met
this
friend she she was actually the first
person to talk to me even though I
looked so weird um she she looks normal
I can say that she just looks like a
girl and she came to me it's like he
what's your name I'm like her name's
Daisy Etc and we ended up building a
very close
friendship we went out drinking that
stage it was all about the beer because
it's all our students could afford so we
went to clubs and we would have a few
beers and so we were living life as we
thought you know this should live go out
drink smoke and all that stuff every day
at the cafeteria we will sit we will buy
ourselves a cup of coffee and have a
smoke or two before we start the day so
I build this friendship with
her and it was interesting because I
didn't see her in a romantic way it was
just a friendship that's it and uh she
was my only friend at that stage and I
was in high school and primary school I
always I was most of the time I was
alone because people didn't
understand how to be my friend if I
could say that I did they were friends
um in
fact I am 100% convinced that this one
girl in high school was probably an
angel of God because I try to find her
but afterwards but I couldn't find her
and she she came in so in such a right
time where I needed someone the most and
um and this friend of mine I figured was
similar because I needed this friend she
was good to me she cared for me and
again she gave me that sympathy and that
empathy in that year
I got exposed to
anime and I know you guys did a
documentary on anime which I recommend
everybody to watch as well um so anime
for me at first I love the style of it I
studied Fine Arts and so I I loved
artist
artistic uh creations of different how
people paint how they draw everybody was
so different at that campus and so yeah
and so I I looked at this anime at first
I was like wow it's really nice drawing
it's really nicely presented it looks so
good but after a while I I didn't even
notice the the type of art I just like
wow the story line I can totally relate
to some of these anime characters so I
got so hooked because now for the first
time there are characters or people that
understands me right so I started to
yeah and I I I just took it in more and
more until I discovered that wow it's
it's yeah it's it's evil yeah it's
sadistic some of it and yeah
there's hardcore in it and there were
all these aspects to it and I didn't
realize at first how damaging that was
but for me I was just so captivated by
it and um
the because some of
it they
were
same in there as well and I I remember
thinking is this for kids I mean the
kids actually watch this but then I
learned that now that you get different
types of anime but still there are
teenagers that even watch this kind of
stuff and it looks innocent I mean it
sounds innocent they like oh no my child
is watching anime
so so are you saying that that there's
is is is same attractiveness and same in
a lot of the anime or is it just like
you know you you just came across it see
at
first it was my
friend that she made a friend and that
friend gave her anime and it wasn't the
stuff that they gave me is probably one
of the most top ones and that's um
bleach and
Naruto and now those type those two
anime was the first ones that I was
drawn to because there were elements
that I could really relate
to but they weren't gay
interactions but they were suggestions
like there a lot of suggestive
stuff so I was waiting for those kind of
um interaction
whether lgbtq or just normal re
reactions uh interactions but I didn't
see it so I just kept watching and
watching waiting for it but that whole
time while I was indulging myself and
just hiding myself in
anime I I tried to look for my
identity in that process I figured well
I can really to all of those characters
maybe I can find myself in those
characters wow so I just get I came so
addicted to it because I want to know
who I am I I accepted that I had same
sex attractions but now anime is going
to teach me what I need to know about
myself so would you say that that
watching the
anime um kindled your uh homosexual or
lesbian lifestyle even more oh
absolutely wow
absolutely in fact they were act there
are reports of a man that wanted to
marry an anime
character wow that is how deep that is
how deep the addiction can go and it was
in anime that drove my same sex
attractions even more
wow and I wanted
I so much so like that guy that wanted
to marry an anime character I I I wanted
to live in anime so much so that I I
thought I was happy there because they
understand me and uh at home every time
when I would get home I would close my
eyes I would put blanket over my head
room was dark and and I would utter the
word
safe because
reality for
me was
cruel but my
fantasy my imagination was whatever I
wanted to be so when I was alone in the
dark cover head covered I I felt no safe
and now I create a world World in my
mind what I want it to be where I'm the
hero like all of those characters and I
look like those female characters
because they always
pray portrayed with that a certain
physique right and now I had that
physique I look like that girl but I act
like that guy uh so I just created this
whole fantasy in my mind and for me that
Fant y was reality and reality was not
real that's how I cope and it started
with anime so so you mentioned earlier
that at one point you you were U
noticing that these were programs that
kids were watching but there's like
hardcore including uh lesbian and gay
there was that the time you kind of
start waking up to this and your own
lifestyle or you know was it just a
warning signal but you ignored it how
did it happen I look I ignored it
because from a very young age by the age
of eight I knew what was and from that
age I got addicted
to so from a young age I thought that
was normal though when I saw that these
kind anime the kid animes
has suggest suggestiveness I don't know
how to call it it wasn't somewhere
hardore
cor but there were some that was very
suggestive in a way as if you were to
watch the documentary that little eye
Studios that you guys made the first one
uh from anime um the Dragon Ball Z one
that I was so addicted to um
specifically had
subtle suggestiveness all right in other
words this one scene where this old
creepy guy asked the girl can I see your
underwear and she's like in order for
him to do her a favor and she just lift
up her dress and she didn't have any
underwear on and that show was for kids
right and I thinking what but I I
thought that was normal wow I thought
that that's
normal but uh it it so it didn't trigger
any warning signals for me and something
I have to mention is while being so
addicted throughout my whole uh time
that I was studying at the University as
I got more and more addicted to it I
didn't realize this is important I
didn't realize that anime gave Satan
access to my heart without me really
realizing it I opened a door for him to
just enter into my life and um
since then I've been having terrible
nightmares demonic nightmares and uh I
didn't understand it and so much so I
started to really like horror films the
more gruesome the better so my mind just
I was so confused I didn't know who I
was I thought I'm like this but I act
like that um I I'm attracted to girls I
I don't know who I am and I'm loving all
this gruesome stuff I'm loving
and I just thought well this is how life
is I'm just going to live it and uh it
was only my third
year of studying that my friend and that
she broken off the friendship now I
remember she was my only friend and I
had loneliness issues and in that time
when she broke off the friendship I fell
into this ridiculous depression and
um at that I still remember it I was in
my room and um that day she broke the
Friendship off and there was this Bible
on my uh desk and I'm just looking at
this Bible and I'm
like okay
God yeah I I I knew about God and some
were exposed in my life um you know
sometimes we would go to it was in in
primary school we go to church on Sunday
and we come home and you know it's just
normal days usual have a beer have this
smoke you know it's no big deal so I
knew there was a God and so I looked at
this
Bible my my parents got that Bible for
me when I was 16 I remember I was so
disgusted I like this is not what I want
for my birthday I dare you so I just put
it side but when I studied that one
night the Bible was there and I
specifically noticed it I was always
there but you know I didn't pay much
attention to it but that night I noticed
that Bible and I said Okay God this is
how it is
okay if you let me speak to my friend
she comes to me and she speaks to me
then I will read that
Bible after I made that promise I was
like God I will read this Bible if you
let me speak to her and she speaks to me
because she flat out ignoring me I mean
I can walk to her she will walk the
other way I would look at her she would
look the other way like she had no
interaction with me whatsoever and it
was so weird because we were so close we
went through a lot together um but she
was just like sorry it's over so that
night
I asked God and funny enough I somehow
thought or realized maybe I should kneel
so that thought just came into my mind
okay I'll KNE at my bed now ask God
please help me in
this it was a week after and here she
comes and she's like so you want to
talk she came and spoke to me and I was
dumb struck I just stood there for a few
seconds and she's like
well and I'm like yeah okay all right
all right uh yeah let's go to cafeteria
and that is when she told me that she
seven the ADV and why she broke off the
Friendship is because she realized that
the life she was leading was not
according to God so she kind of gave her
life over to God again
and uh so she told me all of this and
then she said she cut out everything
that could distract her from that
relationship with God and that included
me now at first I didn't understand it
but the fact that she was talking to me
I just I took it all in and then she
started to tell me all these different
kind of Bible truths I'm like what how
come nobody told me this stuff this is
good stuff it's better than anime
but I still watched anime but
nonetheless that is where she that is
where God kind of grew that seed for me
and uh I I wanted to learn more and more
about
God and I for some reason there was this
just huge hunger for it the more I heard
the more I wanted to know and so this
one time I asked my friend okay so you
go to church on Saturday and she's like
yes at first when she told me she was a
Seventh Day Adventist I looked at her
I'm like you're a what
now like I'm a Seventh Day Adventist
like what is that like no we go to
church on Saturdays okay and she
explained it to me and uh the one time I
asked her listen can I go to church with
you on Sabbath well this sabbath she's
like yeah sure now you can imagine I
already looked so so strange always
wearing boy clothes extremely short hair
so that went well I was petrified of the
whole situation but nonetheless it went
well and that I remember that first day
of church um there was a baptism of an
80-year-old man and I just remember
looking at this
baptism I'm like this guy is 80 years
old almost more than half of his life
life is over but now I decided to follow
God and I was so captivated by this that
afterwards I went straight to the pastor
remember I looked very strange okay I I
I knew that I probably have to get a
skirt to go to church so my dad has this
friend Indian Indian lady who's who sold
these Indian
skirts so I wore that and whatever
decent shirt I could find to church and
I just went up right to him
and I told him hey I also want to get
baptized that was my first time in that
church and I told him I want to get
baptized you better do something that's
amazing and he very kindly yeah and he
very kindly said all right sure no
problem and then they started studies
with
me and
uh it
was while we were doing studies there
was this Youth Camp I remember the final
in my third year the final year so at
this at this Youth
Camp everything was paid for for me to
go I don't have any money I I just
discovered this new Faith this new
church I asked to be baptized I didn't
know anything about youth camps in fact
I feared public places with people
because public places was everybody's
always staring at me because they
couldn't figure out what I
was and so I thought ah this is going to
be hard but it wasn't I arrived and
everybody was so friendly and
accepting and uh at the end of that
Youth Camp the the director that hosts
the camp of this
ministry they he asked is there anyone
that wants to serve in this
ministry um they only need like five
people
and I was like yeah that's what I want
to do I want to be in that Ministry I
want to learn more about this God and
so I in I served in that Ministry for 10
years and in that 10 years was trial and
error for me because in the beginning I
was still looking very very strange but
funny
enough as I grow more in Christ phys
physically I started to change more and
more without realizing it I started to
look more like a woman so I started to
discover my
identity and I thought wow so I'm not a
boy I I don't have any desires for all
these horror movies and
Anime I don't have a desire for any of
those I just have a desire for God and
the more I grew in God the more I
realized
that I am a woman in Christ that is my
identity I was like
finally I know what I am and I'm not
confused about it it's really it's
really amazing how how you were trying
to find your identity in anime so much
so that you wanted to be an anime
character um and and and those anime
shows included like you mentioned
suggestions of of relations and
homosexuality and that you couldn't find
it there but you found it in Christ
which didn't have that even though you
were living that
before exactly exactly I I felt
fulfilled I felt like I learned what
love was love is wasn't lust I thought
that's what it was it wasn't no God
showed me what real love was and I just
grabbed on to it because I didn't have
that throughout my whole life and now
finally God loves me for me and he
showed me who I was now after that
Ministry I I spent all those 10 years
serving God but nearing the
end I realized that I can't just ignore
my past because there was so much trauma
so much stuff that happened that I never
really dealed with while serving in this
ministry but near the end it's like
everything just came
crashing at once and I
remember having that desire again for
anime so I looked for it and I found it
and I started watching anime again
and I realized that
I I gave so much of myself for God that
I didn't give God the chance to give
back to me so in that time of the
ministry I I discovered who I really was
but realizing that I I I still have to
deal with this trauma I didn't want to
deal with the trauma so I fell back and
I let go of God at that
stage and
um I tell you God has given me amazing
people in my life that they helped me
throughout that whole time supporting me
helping me deal with all this trauma and
when I came out of
that it's like I was a new
person I I there was this one time while
I was de um dealing with all of that
drama remember I mentioned before that
anime I gave
enemy gave Satan access to my heart
mhm during that time while I was during
dealing with my
trauma there was this uh specific
meeting uh these people came down to
teach us how to uh counsel people and so
we came for the training it was me and a
few of the ministry
members and I remember remember that
they wanted to show us how to pray uh
with people how to guide them in prayer
and I was the example and uh for them so
I sat there and the people that was in
that Ministry uh that's teaching sat in
front of me across the table and
everybody else was in a circle around us
to observe uh how this is going to go so
we started off with this
prayer and um I looked I looked up at
her and I had this tremendous anger in
me I just couldn't understand it was so
much rage and I looked at her I was like
why am I so angry and they're like
that's okay just continue and this rage
just started to
multiply and and just it got so
overwhelming that I clenched my fist and
my
teeth and at that stage people realized
hang on something's going on here there
is something demonic going on here and
it it took about 2 hours if not then my
eyes was closed I was
clinching my jaw was cleaned my hands
and I was filled with all this rage but
I just sat there and I was
shaking was it was it actual demon was
it actual demon possession you think or
what was it from anime it was so like
watching anime resulted in you being
demon-possessed
exactly anime opened that door for Satan
to come in and just take over and the
more I indulged in it the more he just
entered in me and I I didn't know it I
didn't realize it at that stage because
I was at this ministry and I'm serving
God and it's genuine service right my
life completely changed in that
Ministry it's almost like it that side
was
suppressed until the time where Satan
was like ah now I got you now this is it
and I realized in that moment that Satan
was angry
because God is about to break that chain
that Satan had on me and he didn't want
to let me go
so the whole time in the prayer the
people the
the person that was praying with me they
Tred to get me to choose Jesus to say
that I choose Jesus and I couldn't cuz
my jaw was just clenched after two hours
clenched
and I eventually said I choose Jesus
that the moment I said it I was
completely calm
and I looked up and I saw everybody
around me in that Circle was crying wow
and I realized that they were praying
for me they were fighting for Satan to
get rid of this hold that he had on
me wow and I felt so calm I felt
complete everything changed from there
everything
changed and not long after that coming
our Ministries came on the SE and I was
like listen I got some stuff to
share I want to tell others like I know
I want to tell them listen I know how
you feel let me tell you something
there's
hope so yeah it was quite it was quite
the journey it quite the
journey while you
were in the midst of that and you begin
to sense an identity that God was giving
you it just shows the supernatural power
power of the Holy Spirit when you engage
with something that you expect that's
tangible like like the anime or even
individuals in our lives sometimes but
when we begin to invest ourselves in in
finding out what God's Will and plan
is it it's amazing with that invitation
the the power of Jesus Christ that takes
over to to hearts that are softened to
hearing that voice yeah absolutely it's
amazing to see that happen and then the
transformation begins and and of course
you know you're living continuing to
live that out now with h coming out
Ministry
so yeah get I I gave God permission yes
to to take this away from me to teach me
how what is my identity and he did and I
found it in God that was the only place
where I found my true identity and that
was with God not the world the world was
teaching me all sort of stuff that just
confused me but God know me he knew me
since before I was born knows every hair
number of hair on my head I at first I
thought wow that's profound God knows
that much about me so I just want to
learn more about him and after dealing
with all of my trauma getting out of
that satanic hold that Satan had on me
after that everything was super clear to
me I want want to serve God as much as I
can as long as I can and I want to
encourage others that went through the
same thing as I did so that's why I
wanted to join coming out
Ministry firsthand I was like Michael
please use me as best you can so so you
know you you ones live that lifestyle
you've decided not to uh live a life as
a lesbian uh
anymore can I ask you do you still have
same-sex attraction at this point or
Satan wasn't going to let me go that
easy because oh we know sin is in this
world and Satan is always going to make
suggestions to you and he's always going
to try and tempt tempt you so because I
had that for had that for half my life
that same sex attraction they were still
there and I still found women attractive
but I never ever ever had the
desire after I went through all of my
traumas all of
that pain that I had to go through um
after Satan was or that hold of Satan
was released from me after that yeah
there was still that attraction but I
never went for it yeah I never wanted it
that's the thing so Wayne I know that
you you mentioned once that you know uh
you you still have same seex attraction
but both of you have decided that Jesus
is more wor worth it right and and the
world tells you do what do whatever you
want to do Alish dley who is considered
one of the biggest Satanist occultist
that ever lived he said do what thou
Wilt shall be the whole of the law
whereas God says I have my Ten
Commandments and if you follow them and
Obey them all 10 of them and and follow
whatever my teachings are in Old and New
Testament I have a better life for you
so for this may be a question for both
of you guys like what is it for you that
you found in
Jesus that is worth so much that you say
at rather set aside the old lifestyle
even if Satan tempts me you know even if
somebody comes by that seems attractive
or the same sex I don't want that I want
Jesus what what is it I think with that
when there's an honesty in ourselves to
recognize that there's an actual battle
that's taking place so somebody who
doesn't considered the battle you know
it's not as tangible but for somebody
who has known a different life they've
seen the evil tensions in the world and
then you come in contact with the truth
you know of Jesus Christ what he
promises um what he what he miraculously
does the way that he's pre proved
himself to me personally um his patience
his endurance his
longsuffering um the the blood he shed
for me uh the fact that he doesn't give
up on me even when I have felt giving up
on him um that's a that's a supernatural
power and in anyone who has lived in a a
deep dark culture can come back to
Christ and and physically know that the
enemy is not so willing to let go and so
there is going to until Jesus comes
there will be uh an
overwhelming uh
um challenge to the enemy to try to pull
me back into that world he knows that I
have touched it smelled it felt it and
he knows that if he can tangibly you
know put that before my
senses that's his Avenue to my soul
whereas Jesus Avenue to my soul is
through the Holy Spirit and through my
surrendering and submitting to him and
if I'm not surrendering and submitting
those old passions will awaken and come
alive so my only safety as I've said you
know over the years is in a constant
abiding relationship with Jesus what
about you Daisy what is it about
Jesus that is so desirable that
everything else just becomes pale
including living a life as a
lesbian um the one thing was happiness I
was looking for it my whole life and I
thought I found it in all these
different ways that I was looking for it
in the world
anime uh but when I met God there was a
happiness that I never felt before ever
in my life and that happiness is I I
could only find in God God makes me
happy not the same sex lifestyle not the
ALG BT
lifestyle and I don't want to go back
there because what I have now is so much
more fulfilling so much
more
H it's more it's so much more I actually
don't know how else to describe it
um when Satan tempts
me and I don't want it is something I
always do with temptation before the day
starts I submit my thoughts because we
can't sin Even in our thoughts Bible
teaches that if you so much think think
of lasting you know it's like you're
sinning it so when those thoughts come
into my mind this is one thing I do I
Surrender it and I say God I don't want
these thoughts please take it away and
he does every single time and I feel so
relieved like when I when I when Satan
tries to temp me I feel heavy and sad
but when I Surrender it to God I feel so
much lighter and I was like yeah I iin
never going to go back there again
there's nothing for me there it's only
Darkness only sadness only depression I
don't want that anymore God has
something for me so much better than the
life I have lived and I want more of
that yeah I think it's you know it's the
promise believing in the promise
because it you know in my walk it's it
it has been personally difficult at
times even believing and and being back
in agreement with God that I still have
felt the loneliness the darkness the
pull um because even in church
communities sometimes they're not
they're not as full bodied as as a
person would would like I think even for
heterosexual singles they can be made to
feel like they're a little bit on the
outside or not included or they can't
they don't get to go home to a spouse
and two children and stuff so you know
I've had even those considering Jesus
who have listened to me say no I do
experience times of loneliness and like
like see it doesn't work and I said but
it does work because I have the promise
of eternal life I have the promises of
Jesus I have I have to know that there's
a life after this that isn't tainted
with the loneliness and the Darkness of
this world anymore and so I live in that
promise and I believe in claiming the
truths of Jesus as opposed to what the
world has to offer me so even though it
can be difficult you know a life of a
Christian can sometimes be a little bit
more difficult than if we were just
floating through life and doing what
pleased our senses but but it but it
really is those promises um that I know
that in the world Beyond this that I
will have you know Bliss I will have um
you know communion with Christ a
wholeness in him that I that I haven't
totally experienced I've had the
beginnings of it on this Earth but it
will come to completion you know the
Philippians 1:6 that he says that he
will finish the work that he began in US
yeah and the Bible also says that he
will give us peace above all
understanding so I believe that all of
us whatever we're going through we can
claim that promise it gives you that
peace exactly sometimes peace and joy
isn't in exuberance you know you don't
physically see it on somebody's face but
that you know that when somebody's been
through something horribly traumatic or
you can't even imagine what it would be
like to be them but you see a piece in
their eyes you know that they have a
faith that really just transcends you
know anything that's comparable on this
Earth yeah so there might be somebody
watching who is currently part of the lb
lgbtq plus
Community what kind of a message would
you guys have for someone like that who
might be thinking like what about your
Jesus you know is he worth it um is it
is it is it worth taking the risk to
take a step into that direction what's
your message for someone like
that well for me because I've been there
and I know what it's like to live in the
lgbtq lifestyle and I know what it's
like to choose to accept that this is
who I am and nobody's going to change it
I even went so far as to say well God
made me like this so this is who I'm
supposed to be I know what that is like
but I also know that God has something
better for
me and my advice would be there's so
much more than just being lgbtq living
that lifestyle and accepting that
because that is how you feel there's so
much more a better life a better
lifestyle and that is with Christ and
the reason I can say that is a better
lifestyle because I've lived it I can
say that to everyone because I've been
there and this is where I am now and um
and the best advice I can give is my
testimony that you can see it firsthand
amen from me
way yeah the the you know is interesting
in listening to the to the comments
about anime and and there's plenty of
other things there's all kinds of things
out there to draw Us in by our passions
and attentions but those are imitations
and those are things that are made up
whereas the truths of of Jesus are are
you know they're they're just something
that's beyond anything that this earth
and the enemy can manufacture it it's
some Jesus is is worth it because he
says you're worth it and you can put
faith and trust throughout his entire
word you know the promises are there for
us to claim and I think we can see
unwrapping and unfolding before our eyes
the contentions that there are in
between individuals in between races in
between cultures the world is in utter
chaos and yet you know the the only
piece that somebody really has is in
this personalization of Jesus whereas in
a another belief system there isn't
there isn't a God that gave his son
there isn't a representation of someone
who took on you know all our sin all our
guilt all our shame and and died you
know for us so to me he's he's the only
one that's worth living for one of the
big big big issues I don't want to call
it issues but comments that I have heard
or even said myself is God God made me
like this this is how I'm supposed to be
and God loves me no matter what he said
that he loves everyone and he accepts
everyone that's like one of the most
common
um reactions that I've seen and have Sav
myself but
that right there is that right there is
what I've
learned from the world remember I didn't
know I didn't really know God and I
didn't really know what he had to offer
the world taught me since I was a child
shaped my world view but
God changed my world view to what is
true to what is pure and what is just
and it's so much
better than what the world teaches Daisy
um for somebody who is well regardless
of of there being LGBT but if they're
immersed into this um secret and Dark
World of anime if they were wanting to
communicate with you how would they go
about doing that do you have an email
address should they contact you through
coming out Ministries or what's the best
way to to because somebody with
firsthand experience can certainly you
know speak to this a lot better you know
maybe they can do it through coming out
Ministries rather because it's a
Ministry and people can also
uh reach out to coming on Ministries as
well while asking for me again thank you
so much Daisy for being here with us
sharing your testimony it's so powerful
and so amazing to see what God has done
in in both of you guys' lives and for
those at home thank you so much for
watching please make sure you comment uh
down below let us know what you think
hit the Subscribe button if you want to
hear her story about anime that's coming
out as well also we've got t-shirts
Christian t-shirts I'm wearing one right
now you can go to lightwear do shop uh
this also supports the YouTube channel
and you can wear your witness and share
Christ Light with the world um we also
got a new YouTube channel called little
life kids where you can find wholesome
kids content Christian kids content
we're working on all kinds of shows
right now that are going to be on there
soon so please make sure you subscribe
and also we have a podcast if you want
to learn more about the Bible we have an
in-depth podcast free to listen to uh
just subscribe to Little Light Studios
podcast wherever you listen to your
podcasts in any podcasting apps that's
it for today everyone thank you so much
for watching and we'll see you next time
[Music]
bye and he for you
is in the temple of my God and he shall
go out no more I will ride on him the
name of my
God in the and in the
shall your strength shall
M shall
run I alone but by every word that
proceeds from the mouth of God
[Music]
it's proven that people remember things
that they see more than what they hear
lightwear believes the best way to share
your witness is to wear your witness
lightwear has all kinds of graphic te's
that are a great attention grabbing way
to share the gospel so head on over to
lightwear do shop and check out all the
cool graphic te's what do you want
people to remember when they see you
[Music]
oh